thank you very much for being with us
Amos camera thank you for having me one
of the things that really stood out to
me when I was reading your book and what
you said about the referendum campaign
was that you said that at the beginning
of that campaign you felt like winners
in waiting
were you a bit arrogant I don't not at
all I always from the moment I called
the referendum I knew that it was gonna
be a huge fight and incredibly difficult
what I meant by that phrase was that the
economic argument we had I felt really
on top of that that the single market
was important to jobs important to
businesses we had so many businesses on
our side so many experts making these
arguments that it felt like a winning
hand and then I try and tell the story
in the book of how the winning hand
became the losing hand you didn't really
understand the mood of the country did
you that's the truth that I don't accept
that actually if you go back although I
was a modernizing conservative I was one
of the first politicians in a long time
to make very serious speeches and
attempt to get immigration under control
which I think was the huge concern to
people and politicians had been pushing
it to one side for too long and I think
the mood of feeling that globalization
and the economic crisis has left people
behind economically and left some people
behind culturally and that change have
been too fast I think we did understand
that but as I say in the book we didn't
do enough to address it but I think we
were we were trying to answer the right
questions but we needed to move faster
and harder and you were a student of
history does it pain you that you'll go
down in history is the man who breaks
the emotion well it pains me what I see
has happened since because we've had
three years of hiatus we seem stuck now
to be fair to Theresa May she produced a
deal for us to leave the EU and I think
it was wrong for the people who most
wanted brexit to reject that deal which
is why we are where we are but as I try
to explain in the book that I believed
our position in the EU was becoming
unsafe and unstable particularly after
the treaty veto in 2011 where we had
genuine concerns but the EU just pushed
ahead and had a treaty anyway same
people same offices in table same chairs
and it showed they could do
without unanimity we needed to fix that
and that is where the renegotiation and
the referendum came from what I believe
they were inevitable I'm interested to
know your thoughts on the current state
of the conservative party I interviewed
Sanh Jima Lost Weekend so when who was
your parliamentary private secretary as
prime minister he's then join the Lib
Dems and he said to me if I want to find
some politics the liberal values and the
Conservative Party is no longer the
place to do so I mean are you worried
conservatism is slipping away I do worry
but I think Sam who I admire normally
he's a friend and was a great PPS to me
I think he has made the wrong choice
because although brexit dominates
everything at the moment if for one
moment you just leave it to one side and
look at what the Conservative Party is
today it is totally different to the one
that I inherited in 2005 it has got a
far better gender balance it's got far
more people from across the country it
represents seats in the north and
Midlands and not just the south and if
you listen to the concerns of
conservative MPs they are talking about
education reform and stalled opportunity
and tackling modern slavery and all
those issues and environmentalism and
and green causes so we need to deal with
brexit but is the cause of a modern
compassionate conservative party lost
absolutely not
and now we've got to talk the Queen one
of the first rules and I think I've said
everything I want to say so you can ask
me questions but I'm going to say very
very little I will ask you the questions
one of the first wars in politics is
that you don't talk about private
conversations with the Queen and you've
done that twice firstly you were
recorded saying she paid down the line
to you when you told to the results that
Scottish referendum and secondly you've
now revealed as well that you asked her
to raise Aniyah and she that's I mean I
was what I said in that program and I
don't want to add to it in any way it
was about conversations between my aides
and her aides actually so what you asked
is not actually great but I don't want
to say any been in disgrace I don't want
to say anymore the rule family the
source of our comparison said that your
comments caused displeasure
I mean that means they're furious in
ruel family speak when you're the one
who's brought this up though you're the
person who has made these revelations
and the context was as I said that Alex
Salmond was saying that her Majesty
would be the proud monarch of an
independent Scotland there was a
frustration in my team and that's why
the conversations between one set of
AIDS and another set of AIDS took place
but that's that's it I mean it's clear
that you feel uncomfortable talking
about this are you sorry well I'm I
don't want to say any more because I
don't want to make the situation worse
than it is so you can go on asking
questions any more okay well let's talk
about your record in government then and
because for many people your government
was symbolic of austerity between 2010
and 2016 the number of people sleeping
rough doubled food bank usage went up I
mean you were talking about
compassionate conservatism is that the
record of compassionate consult as a
record of the government is that we cut
the budget deficit by two-thirds we
created two and a half million jobs
there are a million more businesses we
became the fastest growing economy in
the g7 inequality fell the number of
people in poverty fell the number of
households where no one worked fell
massively and we ended up with an
economy with more people in work and at
any time in our history I'm not saying
we solve all the economic problems of
the UK but the program worked Britain
was a standout economic success story by
2014-2015 when we went back to the
electorate and won a freshman date but
some of these impacts take some time to
be felt I mean how many police officers
did you cut well we did have to make
cuts to many public services because we
were living way beyond our means I mean
I became prime minister in 2010 when
Britain was forecast to have the biggest
budget deficit anywhere in the world so
how many people what we achieve what we
demonstrated was actually you could
reduce police budgets while continuing
to cut crime and actually trying to
increase the number of neighbourhood
officers that were on the front line and
that is what happened and there was some
wastage and inefficiency and all of
these public services and we had to do
something about that but as I say you
know I'm happy to be judged on what
happened to there are number one tasks
that government
turn the economy around create jobs give
people a better chance in life we did
those things my question was how many
police officers were cut it was twenty
thousand police officers and although I
do acknowledge that you say that crime
fell while you were Prime Minister what
many feel has happened since then is
that crime has gone up so for example if
we just look ABS since 20 2011 the
number of offenses involving knives
increased by 30 percent crusted a dick
the head of the Met Police says there is
some link between violent crime on the
streets obviously and police numbers of
course there is and everybody would see
that do you see that I think the mistake
made in knife crime has has many causes
and there are many things that we need
to do to tackle it and I absolutely
think it was right of Sajid Javid when
he was Home Secretary to look again at
stop and search because actually the
number of police officers clearly has an
impact but as big an impact is what are
they doing and if you're not using
acknowledge then I think the key thing
was the stop and search that's what
needed to that's what needed to change
and as I say as we reduce police budgets
actually we were able to make sure that
there was more on the frontline that's
absolutely crucial but if you're asking
me did we make difficult decisions yes
of course we did but we had no choice I
mean I'm been quiet that are three years
but sometimes druman be mad to hear that
somehow austerity was a political choice
that there were other alternatives we
faced a clear and present danger of
having such a massive budget deficit we
had to sort that out and we did it and
did it in a way where inequality fell
poverty fell and we got many more people
into work we cut jobs from the public
sector yes we had to but we actually
replaced those not wonderful one with
jobs in the private sector but five four
one five jobs created in the private
sector for every job lost in the public
sector you see many people will be
listening to you now they'll read what
you said in the book which is that we
probably didn't cut enough and they'll
think you just don't get it what I said
what I say the book is that you should
when you when you win an election on the
basis of saying as we did very clearly
we're going to have to make difficult
decisions we're going to have to make
cuts there is an argument for not having
to make more and more difficult
decisions in year two three and four but
try and do more things earlier and I try
and be frank in the book about things
that we got right and things that we got
and what'd you send the pic as my
assessment now is that we probably
didn't cut enough we could have done
more even more quickly earlier I think
that's the point is I think we could
look we had to make difficult decisions
including putting up some taxes which we
we did we had a balanced program and you
know we we ended up with the top 1%
ending up paying 27 percent of all the
income tax take which is the highest has
ever been in our history was there not
let's not write a tax but we actually
what's much more important than the
actual tax rates is who's paying what
and the top 1% of earners in our country
and our paying 27 percent of the total
income tax take that's the highest it's
ever been and I think you should judge
governments on that more than what the
headline rates are very catchy great for
budgets but really what matters is who's
paying I mean you're talking about
difficult decisions but in an interview
this week when you asked of an example
of something that perhaps you've got a
bit wrong you said forestries people
know you don't understand I do
understand it there were many difficult
decisions I was just trying to think of
an example of something where an
enormous amount of controversy was
caused by by a change that was not sort
of core to what we were trying to do and
that's what I picked and Boris Johnson
has now said that austerity isn't an end
he's turned the spending caps back on
it's a mistake no I think it's great
that because we hook difficult decisions
and we got that budget deficit down that
we are able to spend more I mean if you
go back to what I said when I was leader
of the opposition when the economy grows
what you ought to do is share the
proceeds of growth between extra public
spending keeping people's taxes down and
making sure that your debt position is
sustainable I hope we don't forget that
having a debt GDP ratio that is
manageable is terribly important and I
know that sounds very dry but what it
really means is when the next crisis
comes along do you have the capacity to
step in and help with the extra public
spending you might need in some areas
and tax reductions you might need in
some areas so keep an eye on that would
be my advice too - Boris as well as
quite rightly spending some more money
on key public services now that we're
able to fix the return of sunshine it
fix the roof on the sun shining is
have you given any advice to you Boris
Johnson I have we've we text each other
from time to time I haven't had a
meeting with him since he's been Prime
Minister he's very busy
he knows my views on most things the
most important thing he is trying to do
he has my support for which is going to
Brussels getting a deal bringing that
deal back and trying to end this period
uncertainty and I wish him well as he
does that had he taken a new view of
ISIL well that he is I think we're as
one with her claim to be the author of
that there was something you wanted to
do but I'm encouraging him you know No
Deal is not a good idea
breaking the law is not a good idea
focus everything you've got on on
getting that deal and that's what he's
doing to be fair to him what and have
you been doing since you were president
of Alzheimer's Research UK which is a
charity that's battling hard to try and
find some solutions to the dementia
crisis that we face in government we did
a lot to increase research and to
increase awareness about dementia so I'm
getting that a lot of attention I'm
still president of National Citizen
Service the youth volunteering program I
set up that one in six 16 year olds did
this summer I do some work with the
Oxford School of Government and others
on how we help the most fragile states I
want to continue the legacy of the fact
we did meet the North point seven
percent target for aid and even in
difficult circumstances we should
remember there are people living in dire
poverty on the other side of the world
and it's a moral cause but it's also a
cause that's right for us I mean these
problems come and visit us if we don't
deal with them at source so those are
some of the things I'm I'm doing well
well I finished the book so perhaps I
have a bit more time to do some other
things how much have you earned since
leaving office I haven't counted up I
run a small office of five people or six
people actually since we've been doing
the book and I am giving all the
prophets of the book so after I've paid
for the editors and researchers the
prophets of the book we'll all go to
charities chiefly dementia charities
disabled children's charities and
charities for our armed services who you
know when you've been Prime Minister I
think you feel a particular
responsibility too because you asked
them to work so hard on your behalf I
mean you've been doing quite a lot of
species as well I mean we talked about
in the region of a million pounds you in
the Tony Blair level so on your show to
talk about politics political issues the
books rather than other stuff okay and
one of the things that I will always
will very much remember after reading
your book is and the way you talk about
your family and and in particular of
course about your son Ivan and I just
wonder do you feel that going through
something like that as a family gives
you a different perspective when it
comes to the political issues that you
get asked about all the time Frank so
austerity I think it gives you a
perspective it changes a perspective
because that we all experience the NHS
we go to our GP when we get ill we go to
arey we all have different experiences
but the intensity when you have a
profoundly disabled child of social
workers night carers tubes medicines
tube feedings seizures any over and over
again nights and hospitals different
hospitals different scans different
checks different tests the intensive of
it all and the amazing side of our
health service you see you know district
nurses that it is incredibly dedicated I
think that gives you a perspective I
think also I mean it can affect families
in lots of different ways but I think
with us it brought us closer together we
thought we've got to cope with this we
we don't know quite what we're doing we
didn't volunteer for it we've got to
make it work and I think it it brought
us closer but I mean it's really your
friends I think no just this almost more
than you do because you're living in the
middle of it but some friends said to me
I think it changed your outlook and your
thinking and who you were a bit and I
kind of think that they're probably
right I think when you were saying that
and that it brought you closer together
that certainly comes across you know
with you and Samantha as well
I mean it's she's somebody who's
influential politics yes I mean she's
she's not a political junkie she's
interested but she has a very good sort
of 40,000 foot view and so sometimes
I'll be wrestling with something and she
will be very good when I explained it to
it
well obviously don't you think this
that's what you you know you know she
was quite good at getting you to back
out of the detail and see the big
picture she ever influenced any of your
policies I think I mean I mentioned this
before on gay marriage where I was on a
journey towards gay marriage I'd back
civil partnerships and I was thinking
this is the answer to make it equal but
she was influential in because I was
sort of like the man under the bonnet
trying to fix well it's not fair of gay
couples can't inherit property or have
the hospital visiting rights so let's
fix this and she was sort of going well
never mind all that that's important but
think of the big picture you know if gay
people want to get married that doesn't
make our marriage worth less why not
have proper marriage equality and that
was when the sort of light bulb went off
so sometimes she was very good at the
big picture also incredibly supportive
and and helpful at times of stress and
difficulty of which there are many and
and then just finally you've been in the
background shall we say for a couple of
years now and they have now burst back
onto the political scene doing a lot of
interviews you can forward to going back
to the Shepherd's house having a bit of
a quiet life yes
I'd look I I think ex Prime Minister's
should on the whole let their successes
get on with it
I've tried to do that for three years to
résumé had a very difficult job boris
has got a difficult job I don't want to
give a running commentary I was very
lucky when I first became Tory leader
every single previous Tory leader was on
my side briefly I mean Margaret Thatcher
John major Michael Howard in dung Smith
William Hague and it gives you an
enormous ability and strength to get on
with the job so I will try not to be
what Linton Crosby used to call Connie
the commentator but from time to time
I'm sure I'll have something to say but
I'm looking forward you know I want is
what I wanted to you know say my piece
about the book and let people read it
and judge it for themselves but I
promise this this camp fest is coming to
an end thank you very much thank you